over 2,000 years ago Euclid showed every
number has exactly one prime
factorization which we can think of as a
secret key it turns out that prime
factorization is a fundamentally hard
problem let's clarify what we mean by
easy and hard by introducing what's
called time complexity we have all
multiplied numbers before and each of us
has our own rules for doing so in order
to speed things up if we program a
computer to multiply numbers it can do
so much faster than any human can here
is a graph that shows the time required
for a computer to multiply two numbers
and of course the time required to find
the answer increases as the numbers get
larger
notice that the computation time stays
well under one second even with fairly
large numbers therefore it is easy to
perform now compare this to prime
factorization if someone told you to
find the prime factorization of 589 you
will notice the problem feels harder no
matter what your strategy that will
require some trial and error until you
find a number which evenly divides 589
after some struggle you will find 19
times 31 is the prime factorization if
you were told to find the prime
factorization of 437,000 231 you
probably give up and get a computer to
help you this works fine for small
numbers though if we try to get a
computer to factor larger and larger
numbers there is a runaway effect the
time needed to perform the calculations
increases rapidly as there are more
steps involved as the numbers grow the
computer needs minutes than hours and
eventually will require hundreds or
thousands of years to factor huge
numbers we therefore say it is a hard
problem due to this growth rate of time
needed to solve it so factorization is
what Cox used to build the trapdoor
solution step 1 imagine Alice randomly
generated a prime number over 150 digits
long call this p1 then a second random
prime number roughly the same size
call this p2 she then multiplies these
two primes together to get a composite
number n which is over 300 digits long
this multiplication step would take less
than a second we could even do it in a
web browser then she takes the
factorization of n p1 times p2 and hides
it now if she gave n to anyone else they
would have to have a computer running
for years to find the solution step 2
Koch's need to find a function which
depends on knowing the factorization of
n for this he looked back to work done
in 1760 by Swiss mathematician Leonardo
Euler